there's a certain amount of arrogance
you need to create things like I should
say this I should do this and I should
put this out in the world I made a great
thing and I should share it and it is
for you even though it's for other
people you know even when we were
talking about about your special it's
like you were really proud of this thing
like there's something you've worked on
for [ __ ] you you would say like I put
five years into this and it was like so
much time in anything dude it was really
cool like I'll be honest with all the
comics that I've spoken to about like
you know you know how to release a
special and that kind of stuff you were
[ __ ] locked in and you said something
funny like it was also sober October
but you were [ __ ] sober and sharp and
you know exercising burning 500 calories
you helped me so much dude I was like I
was right from the start I was like hey
is there anything I should know you're
always really [ __ ] good about it even
when I had like the first like stand-up
clip I was like I think I'll put a clip
up and you're like well make sure to put
you know all the things big shot of your
face big writing I was like okay because
you're like send it to me I'll just do
it and send it back to you I was like
okay by me doing it one of these guys
did it all right right right yeah yeah
by me it's like I put a deck on my house
that I gave you their special was from
this community right here uh but yeah
then the special came and I was like
anything I should know you're like well
yeah what's your what's your um what's
your trailer look like I'm like oh do I
need a trailer I just throw it back bro
yeah yeah it's like what I don't know I
don't know any of this yeah I don't know
what am I supposed to do yeah
the [ __ ] out of it and you went after it
and you had your own ideas and certain
ones like really worked and they
enhanced it in other words I was like
it's a little bit too much so it's kind
of like bring it back but like you were
just really hungry for this thing to be
seen and I thought that was really cool
because a lot of people especially
Comics I think that you know we feel
insecure like promoting our own [ __ ]
which is the dumbest thing in the world
because if you really believe in
something that you've made like you
should want people to see it yeah if you
don't think it's worth seeing then
they're not gonna see it at all it's
hard to be like I don't know here but
like I don't like the all Shucks
promotion yeah I I don't like it because
if you believe in something get behind
it I think Tyler the Creator said it the
best there's a clip that I reposted but
he was like yo you put your [ __ ]
Blood Sweat and Tears into like this is
what you do if you think it's dope let
people know it's [ __ ] dope yeah I had
a comment uh Carla both uh just friends
with Kennison he was just like a helpful
comic when I started and and he was
telling merch after a show I'm like
don't you feel like like a cornball
doing that and he goes no if there's a
keychain maybe but these are my CDs this
is my this is the thing I care about
because no I want more people to see
this yeah that makes sense so you'd be
out with this special was like I want
people to see it yeah this one is
special and it's especially good when
like
when the product is good I find it's way
easier to promote it like when you
believe in the thing right I suppose
like if you're in some shitbox movie and
they're like hey
so it's fun to work with Mila Kunis yeah
yeah and you just know it's like uh yeah
yeah this one was great I left how the
comics have all gotten behind it yeah
it's been really helpful and like yeah
and just people seen it like I've had a
lot of people individually reach out to
me and just be like hey I saw this thing
and it was cool it was like focused on
this one thing but it's still jokes and
non-comics I'm talking about like
friends of mine and uh and uh and their
reactions were great too and I was like
oh wow the special has has breached the
apparated yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I always I always look at that I was
like if my non-comic friends who all
think they're comedy fans they're
they're fans of Comedy yeah but they're
not like locked and locked in when they
start sending the DMS and they start
asking me if I know of a person or
whatever I'm like oh wow you've gone out
it's gotten out yeah these there's the
Rogan sphere which we all exist in and
there are people who are not familiar
with us through that when they're
watching I don't have four and a half
million people who know who I am exactly
yeah isn't that crazy yeah yeah I
probably got 130 000 so the rest but
that's 4.4 is is we can go on and on
about it but like that's the perfect
example like why you do something like
this especially if you really care about
it yeah the best comment is I've never
heard you before this is great it'll
work for you yeah yeah yeah no I was far
I'm curious what was the Jewish
reception versus the non-j oh yes did
Jews get upsetted I was afraid they
might but I really tried to cross my T's
and down my eyes and make sure like like
I was telling before the foreign like
any time you know how like you do a joke
about black people you better know and
like if there's like two black people in
the audience I'll do it this way so it's
not about you yeah you just kind of keep
your eye on them to make sure it's not
like because it's it's race it race
racial racial yeah and so you're like I
just want to make sure it's on the right
side of this so you keep your items so
those two audience members are the most
important audience members of that
they're gonna Define how everybody feels
about that something with any joke you
know women or Latinos or or I don't know
autistic joke whatever you don't want
them to attack you yeah so if I'm doing
a joke about the women in the wigs and I
see I see them in the audience and I'm
doing the joke I'm keeping my eye on
them the whole time and and they're
always loving it they're like someone's
speaking about our experience in a
comedy a sphere it's no way and you know
your [ __ ] you've got to know yourself
yeah yeah that's the thing yeah
filming that Kobe video
yeah there were black people
[Laughter]
um yeah but I thought they'd get madder
but they really didn't they didn't
respectful and like in love [ __ ] yeah
dude yeah I have had some people go
while I was doing it some people like
that's not true if that didn't happen
uh Kabbalah parts or like the the
dropping a piece of ham and soup they're
like that's something wrong like you're
you just don't know enough you're wrong
oh really I was higher up than you were
yeah
but did it make you go back and check a
lot I had a I had a great closer about
Noah knowing the flood and how his wife
had his wife had 40 kids and I was like
the real hero of the story is is well he
had 40 because her story is his wife
because like her [ __ ] must have been so
[ __ ] blown out and couldn't even
carried a baby to term after 30 kids
then I had this whole act out of kids
coming out of the umbilical course human
food and then going back here
and uh it was it was just Crusher and
then some Rabbi and Copenhagen was like
Hey man loved your set brought on my
students that was so funny you know Noah
did not have 40 kids though right and I
was like no you're wrong listen I don't
care say whatever you want that's that's
fine it was hilarious I'm like wait was
are you serious he was yeah I forget
it's three or four and I'm like no and I
looked it up and I'm like we gotta drop
it yeah I don't know it's his childhood
memory so I had to figure out what which
of these is just like vague memories
from childhood that you thought you know
when you think of something but you're
like the context was off yeah
um yeah I definitely thought the sheet
with the whole thing I thought that dude
I learned that on this I my last
religious friend from Yeshiva came and
he was like great we don't [ __ ] that's
never happened I'm like that's not true
Rabbi so-and-so did it and he goes
that's not true Ari it's made up and I'm
like no way where does it come from it
comes from uh a stereotype about seed
about these like this like yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and it came from like the hole in the
middle of like a poncho to hang out the
dry and they were like that must be what
it's for Neighbors songs neighbors
because you put it over so the neighbors
are singing it yeah
yeah and it must have been from that
plus we hate you so like
what's there to do
um that's a big [ __ ] for a dick
though you know what I mean it is a big
hole Yeah it's that part I'm fine with
it but they're cutting off parts of it
so the neighbors are probably like
unless they must have some to spare like
uh
I was so sure was true well I saw it in
unorthodox which like apparently have
you seen the show I saw an episode or
two yeah and I thought that that was
like perfect representation and I'm
pretty sure they do it in the show yeah
I made up [ __ ] that's crazy did they
through in the show I thought they did I
think they were trying to have sex just
with like uh I don't think there was an
actual hole was it yeah but they were
just both wearing how convinced I was of
that is that I made it up in the show
that it wasn't even it yeah and the rib
thing too also you for [ __ ] taking it
out man yeah because it's so easy when
you get like because that's the other
thing like it's [ __ ] truth tellers
here we're Comedians and when you get
the joke it makes people laugh it's good
enough but when you're you're putting it
out and calling it Jew now you have a
different expectation because I didn't
want anybody I was like where are they
going to get it
for all the other [ __ ] if one thing's
wrong everything's wrong yeah and it
also makes a Jewish person I imagine
still in the religion feel like yeah
this guy really does like if you had a
non-truth in there the guy yo [ __ ] this
guy he's just trying to get laughs but
if everything checks out and also when
you speak about religion I don't There's
No Malice there's no animosity you're
not like some atheist where it's like
condescending and patronizing so I think
they don't sense any so it's like oh
we're just having fun I used to do that
yeah oh really I went through a period
of like [ __ ] idiots well yeah that's
what happens when you feel like you were
robbed yeah yeah and then it's like all
right have a good time yeah did
something pull you back or was it just
gross doing mushrooms yeah doing
mushrooms
everyone's got their own path exactly
what do we even do okay so here's one
thing this is my struggle even now it's
like with success less and less things
bother me or I don't want to complain
about less things or I realize that
they're not that important so what do
you talk about exactly yeah you need to
get worked up over nothing but I think
that's to be able to like sports or
politics or something like that or it's
like that's the value of [ __ ] sports
for society it's like you almost need
people to be concerned about a thing
it's given bread give them circus it's
like give them Sports yeah pop culture
helps a lot yeah um but I just don't
give up but right if you don't care then
it's like then what do you talk about
that's why the first thing I saw you
today I was like so how's the new stuff
coming yeah and that's me going is there
another thing you can't be Jewish again
Stanhope said it at some point because
I've talked every about everything that
that really matters bro I wrote it all
out I so what am I going to recover my
feelings on abortion I don't want to do
that I really think that's the greatness
of Burr is how many specials he's put
out and how consistent he's been and
even live at the Red Rocks still the
mental illness of being bothered by
everything yeah yeah you stay mad if
you're mad all the time
yeah exactly you said this about Larry
David and Larry Dave is not even a
stand-up but to be that rich bugged by
things and yeah I'm bugged by the song
yeah you're worth a billion dollars and
you're still bugbusters yeah which is
like an annoying way to live do you want
to be Buster Douglas but like he didn't
really win again yeah
interesting so so that didn't affect you
at all you said you have new now that
you're ready I have new stuff now yeah
it's just not it's just not I had this
all this leftovers so every time I you
know see a homeless guy [ __ ] on a
stoop yeah it's like well that can't go
in this hour but I I gotta are you
who kicked him out of his home do you
think
kicked him out of his home and displaced
him no and Lord not paying your bills
kicks you out of your home yeah I refuse
to accept
yeah
[Laughter]
it's a personal choice